chez le ministre est à vous merci d'être
là merci beaucoup monsieur le président
la commission des lois à madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur
de la commission des lois madame la
rapporteure pour avis mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ne sait pas donc
la première fois que je me présente
devant vous je crois que c'est la 11e
fois que je me présente devant vous dans
le cadre d'une d'une audition sur la
gestion de crise sanitaire
avec un projet de loi qui annonce la
couleur il s'agit plus d'état d'urgence
sanitaire mais bien de vigilance
sanitaire
et pour cause j'ai connu et pourquoi
j'ai connu des contextes où je me
présenter devant vous alors que les
hôpitaux se remplissait que les cas se
comptaient par dizaines de milliers et
que nous étions sur le point de mettre
en place de décréter où l'état d'urgence
localisé ou nationales ou des mesures de
confinement cette fois ci la situation
est différente et pour autant elle
impose cette vigilance sanitaire
que je viens plaidé devant vous devant
vous ce matin
la situation est différente parce
qu'effectivement nous sommes à 5000 cas
de circulation de virus par jour et qu'
il n'y a pas une charge hospitalière qui
soit aussi intense que celle que nous
avons connue et pour autant
avons-nous
devant nous des perspectives de
réductions d'épidémie voir d'écrasement
du virus la réponse est non en tout cas
ni à court ni à moyen terme j'en veux
pour preuve ce qui se passe en europe
vous savez sans doute toute l'europe est
soumise à une augmentation de la
pression épidémique en europe de l'est
là où la vaccination est bien plus
faible qu'en europe de l'ouest l'impact
sanitaire est réel et intense avec des
pays qui affichent des taux d'incidence
extrêmement élevé plus de 700 pour pour
100000 habitants sur sur sept jours je
pense à la roumanie notamment la
lettonie d'autres pays la bulle et la
slovénie et en europe occidentale
il ya le cas anglaise avec une
vaccination qui est insuffisante de la
population l'arrêt de toute mesure vous
le savez de gestion de
la crise
décision qui a été prise au niveau
politique de faire comme si le virus
finalement d'engendrer plus de dégâts et
la basse et du 45000 et bientôt du
cinquante mille cas par jour qui sont
enregistrés avec une charge hospitalière
qui commence quand même à poser des
questions d'ailleurs qu'il commence à
être soulevées au plus haut niveau de
l'état en angleterre vont-ils pouvoir
célébrer les fêtes de fin d'année ne
vont-ils pas devoir finalement mettre en
place un système de pass sanitaires il
se pose des questions parce qu'il voit
bien que la croissance épidémique risque
de ne pas s'y arrêter et qui n'en
maîtrisent plus les tenants et
aboutissants avec une couverture
vaccinale qui est plus faible que chez
nous nos voisins allemands consiste
souvent en exemple qui ont une
couverture vaccinale qui est plus faible
que chez nous ont dépassé les 13 14
mille cas certains jours ils sont en
phase de croissance épidémie qu'ils ont
un taux d'incidence qui est plus élevé
que le nôtre magic pays bas
tous les pays qui nous entourent à
l'exception notable pour l'instant des
pays du sud de l'europe mais parce que
de quoi parlons nous nous parlons de
conditions climatiques plus humide est
plus froide qui sont propices à la
circulation tous les virus notamment les
virus respiratoires telles que la grippe
le vrs qui donna bronchiolite bientôt la
gastro entérite que les français
connaissent bien et donc le coc vide et
nourrit je dirais est logé à la même
enseigne et donc dans l'europe du sud
les conditions climatiques sont encore
un peu plus favorable et un peu moins
propice et la circulation des virus mais
nul doute que l'espagne et l'italie ils
connaîtront prochainement une croissance
épidémies comme la nôtre je dis qu'on
est entré dans une période qui va durer
six mois
jusqu'à au mois d'avril a minima dont
les conditions climatiques sont
favorables à la circulation du virus
donc la première question avons nous une
chance pour qu'en février la situation
sanitaire nous permettent de baisser la
garde et de nous dire que l'on peut
sereinement se priver de la possibilité
d'activer lorsque le moment elle
exigerait des outils de gestion de crise
sanitaire la réponse elle est non et
aucun expert sérieux ne vous dira qu'on
peut considérer qu'en février la
situation sera différente de celle que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui
et encore plus en janvier pourquoi je
vous parle de janvier parce que si nous
devions revenir devant vous en mois de
février avec un nouveau texte de loi ce
texte serait évidemment présenté au
cours du mois de janvier au coeur de
l'hiver qui est le mois de la
circulation virale par excellence locaux
vides n'échappe pas à la règle et nous
l'avons vu l'année dernière
est ce que pour autant nous serons
contraints d'activer tout ou partie des
outils
dont nous vous demandons la possibilité
de désactiver si la situation sanitaire
devait l'exiger là aussi la réponse est
non puisque ce que nous avons appris
avec la vaccination massive c'est que la
pression épidémique est sans doute
désormais moins importante en tant
qu'indicateur de suivi que la pression
sanitaires il ya une décorrélation entre
la pression épidémique et la pression
sanitaire la plus grande étude mondiale
sur l'impact de la vaccination et
française 11 millions de vaccinés 11
millions de non vaccinés 92 % du risque
d'hospitalisation après 50 ans lorsqu on
est vaccinés ce qui veut dire que
autrefois on aurait eu trente mille cas
par jour dans le pays on savait qu'on
avait plusieurs milliers
d'hospitalisations à la clé et plusieurs
centaines de décès aujourd'hui grâce à
la vaccination on sait que si on
atteignait jeudi trente mille pourrait
dire 20000 40000 c'est pas une annonce
que je vous fais mais si on atteignait
30 mille cas par jour on n'aurait pas le
même impact d'ailleurs c'est ce qui
s'est passé pendant la quatrième vague
celle du variant delta on voit très bien
qu'il n'y a plus de corrélation entre le
nombre de contaminations et le nombre de
cas graves c'est tant mieux c'est la
vaccination qui nous protège
je lisais les conditions climatique
exacerbe d'environ 30% la circulation
des virus respiratoires ainsi que le co
vide et de l'autre côté nous estimons
que le pass sanitaires et les mesures de
jauger de gestion qui sont encore en
vigueur permettent de réduire d'environ
30% la circulation du virus est à dire
que sans ces outils qui sont
actuellement en vigueur nous ne serions
pas à 5000 cas nous aurions bien au delà
il suffit encore une fois pour en avoir
le coeur net de regarder du côté autres
manches ce qui se passe en angleterre il
ya d'autres éléments péjoratif qui
peuvent intervenir dans la période à
venir il peut apparaître des nouveaux
variants
jusqu'ici il n'y avait pas de nouveaux
variants qui soit en circulation
identifié aujourd'hui n'y a pas
formellement un nouveau variant mais il
ya un sous type de variants qu'on
connaît bien il ya un sous type du
variant delta s'appelle le à y points 4
points 2 e y pointent 4.2 qui a paru
encore une fois en angleterre issu du
variant delta on connaît encore assez
peu de choses sur ce variant il
ressemble à s'y méprendre comme deux
gouttes d'eau aux variants delta mais
les premières études anglaises qui nous
remontent atteste d'une contagiosité
supérieur aux variants delta de l'ordre
de 10 à 15% ça vous paraît peut-être peu
mais sachez que ce sous type du variant
delta représente déjà 6 % des cas
positifs diagnostiqués en angleterre
c'est à dire qu'il a tendance à se
propager le vite et que ce variant
pourrait provoquer un peu plus de
circulation virale que son que sont le
frère dont il est issu le variant d'elle
la sunni circulent en angleterre vous
savez très bien l'histoire se répète
c'est qu'ils ne circule déjà
probablement iran d'europe bref vous
l'aurez compris dans les prochains mois
on a des raisons d'espérer grâce à la
vaccination massive on a des raisons
d'espérer grâce aux outils de gestion de
sanitaires dont nous disposons notamment
le pass et on a des toutes les toutes
les raisons de rester extrêmement
vigilant à part l'apparition de sous
types de variants circulation exacerbée
du coc vide pendant la période hivernale
et tout cela je vous le dis va nous
emmener à minima de l'autre côté de
l'hiver et probablement pas avant le
mois de mai jeu voir juliet c'est la
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement
demande à la représentation nationale de
lui laisser la possibilité si la
situation l'exigeait d'activer des
outils déjà éprouvée dont on sait qu'ils
fonctionnent et qui protège la
population le pass sanitaires pour part
éventuellement des mesures gestion plus
lourdes telles que l'état d'urgence
localisé d'autre part
et donc nous vous demandons de pouvoir
poursuivre cela jusqu'à la date du 31
juillet c'est les députés ont eu
l'occasion de se prononcer sur cette
question et à majorité ont pour accorder
la confiance au gouvernement sur sur ce
point là il n'a je vous le dis ça
n'empêche pas ça n'empêche pas d'avoir
au contraire un moment d'échangé et de
débat et je viendrai très volontiers
devant vous au cours du mois de février
pour discuter de la situation sanitaire
et vous le savez
commission qu'à chaque fois vous m'avez
demandé c'est tout à fait normal de
venir devant vous je suis venu pour
pouvoir répondre à toutes les questions
qui pouvaient se poser et débattre voilà
l'objet je rentre pas plus dans les
détails j'ai compris qu'on avait peu de
temps mais je préférais faire une
introduction qui expliqué qu'ils
insistent sur la situation sanitaire
actuelle et à venir de manière à donner
la perspective et expliquer pourquoi
nous demandons de renouveler la
confiance dans la gestion de
l'utilisation de ces outils un dernier
mot pour dire que nous ne sommes pas là
dans une période extraordinaire de
prolongation des mesures puisque à deux
reprises je suis devenu vent venu devant
vous pour obtenir la confiance sur dix
mois sur 10 mois et demi alors que là
nous parlons d'une période de sept mois
et demi à 8 mois c'est d'être la perte
d'extension une prolongation et de
prorogation des mesures est plus courte
que lors de deux précédents projets de
loi qui portait sur le même type de
magie l'argent merci merci monsieur le
ministre je propose qu'on nous donnons
la parole à nos deux rapporteurs
monsieur bah d'abord madame bruni
ensuite et puis après monsieur juillet
rassemblement et d'autres collègues qui
souhaitent s'inscrire on comprend les
notes précises pour tous les non
monsieur de questeur merci monsieur le
président monsieur mise d'abord
vous remercier de votre disponibilité
personnelle puisque vous avez répondu
constamment à nos invitations pour
l'échangé et le dialogue et c'est
évidemment très important face à une
crise telle que celle du co vide je veux
également remercier le gouvernement
d'avoir
respecté les prescriptions de la loi du
5 août en ce qui concerne son
information sur les effets économiques
et sanitaires
du nouvel outil que nous avons consentis
à vous donner qui était le pass
sanitaires
possibles d'une audition n'est pas
d'ouvrir le débat entre nous mais de
vous poser des questions pour avoir plus
de précisions et éclairer les positions
que nous serons amenés à prendre d'abord
demain dès demain en commission des lois
et jeudi et dans la nuit de jeudi à
vendredi dans l'examen du texte que vous
nous avez proposé donc je m'en tiendrais
est strictement à quelques questions
mais j'ai observé dans les deux avis du
conseil scientifique du 5 et du 6
octobre que autant le conseil
scientifique estime qu il est absolument
certain qu'elle passe sanitaire a joué
un rôle déterminant pour l'accélération
des vaccinations autant dit-il le rôle
du passani terre en tant que mesures
favorisant la protection d un visite des
individus est plus difficile à mettre en
évidence
le pass sanitaire a été mis en place
début août alors que la décroissance de
l'épidémie du variant delta est plutôt
survenu vers le 20 juillet donc il a pu
contribuer dit le conseil scientifique à
celle de croissance mais il est
difficile de mesurer exactement dans
quelle mesure est-ce que vous avez des
précisions à nous apporter sur
l'utilité qu'a pu présenter le pass
sanitaires pour la prévention des
contaminations ça c'est ma première
question
deuxièmement on a pu observer que si la
viralité
du virus avec ces nouveaux variants n'a
cessé d'augmenter sa létalité n'a cessé
de diminuer et aujourd'hui on est quand
même dans une situation très différente
de celle au pluriel que nous avons pu
connaître jusqu'à présent pouvez-vous
nous nous préciser
quel rapport il y as entre le danger du
virus aujourd'hui et le danger qu'il a
pu avoir dès lors que les vaccinations
sont massifs tout de même en france et
ça c'est un succès qu'il faut absolument
reconnaître et mettre en avant et dès
lors que les personnes contaminées sont
de plus en plus jeune et plus
résistantes au virus
autrement dit nous combattons avec les
mêmes armes une maladie qui n'est plus
la même et qui n'atteint plus les mêmes
personnes exactement je voudrais avoir
des précisions sur votre appréciation de
cette évolution de la situation
par ailleurs vous avez bien le relever
et c'est une source de préoccupation
l'apparition de nouveaux variants le
rôle de l'hiver sur la propagation de
l'épidémie
ce qui se passe à l'est de l'europe et
ce qui se passe en grande-bretagne nous
sommes conscient de ceci mais il ya
aussi des éléments plus positifs
il apparaît de nouveau
moyen de traitement préventif ou curatif
est ce que vous pouvez nous faire un
point sur cette évolution et sur
l'anticipation qu'on peut avoir de la
mise à disposition des prescripteurs et
des patients de ces nouveaux produits
nouveaux médicaments se pose la question
de la poursuite de la vaccination est ce
que vous considérez que
nous avons atteint
ou plutôt pour être plus nuancé nous ne
sommes pas loin d'avoir atteint un
plafond dans les vaccinations
et ou au contraire est ce que on peut
encore espérer gagner quelques marges je
vois que les personnes âgées de plus de
80 ans en france sont
14% à ne pas être encore vaccinés tandis
que dans certains pays voisins il n'y a
que 5 % des plus de 80 ans qui ne sont
pas vaccinés que peut-on faire pour
augmenter le taux de vaccination des
personnes ayant atteint leur grand âge
est ce que la courbe actuelle dont on
sent pour la première vaccination
qu'elle se ralentit la première
vaccination est un bon indicateur
parce que laissent anticiper la seconde
est ce que le gouvernement à envisager
de nouveaux moyens d'action de
communication pour faire redémarrer
le la cour des vaccinations alors qu'on
voit que
c'est le plus en plus difficile parce
qu'on est aux marges
et autres questions sur la vaccination
la troisième dose est ce que le
gouvernement entend
recommander la généralisation de la
troisième dose compte tenu du fait que
la vaccination est de plus en plus enfin
plutôt l'effet du vaccin
dans le temps diminue si monsieur le
questionneur vice-présidente grünig
merci monsieur président aime la
présidente monsieur monsieur le ministre
un merci d'être d'être ici présent nous
avons toujours plaisir à vous à vous
entendre ici et dans l'hémicycle est
également donc merci pour ce matin être
à nos côtés juste avant de de passer aux
questions plus générales
je voulais vous demander si les masques
et le gène était encore nécessaire utile
parce que on voit bien que de plus en
plus en fait les personnes les enlèvent
ou veulent les enlever et ce serait bien
de faire un petit rappel et de comment
on place le masque notamment sur le nez
vous et de vous aimeriez beaucoup la
présidente gruny merci alors j'ai quatre
questions alors tout d'abord
l'obligation vaccinale don qui est une
obligation légale qui a vocation depuis
le 15 octobre à s'appliquent à
l'ensemble des personnes concernées et
ce sur tout le territoire national régie
par le droit commun pourtant force est
de constater que certains territoires je
pense ici aux outre mer particulièrement
aux antilles guyane montrent des taux de
vaccination des soignants
particulièrement en établissement de
santé ou médico sociaux particulièrement
de bas vous avez indiqué dans vos
récentes déclarations que la loi devait
s'appliquer partout mais vous montrer
avec votre collègue ministre d outre mer
une certaine tolérance sur la situation
de ces territoires n'est-il pas
paradoxal d'avoir une souplesse
d'application dans des territoires
dernièrement dans une situation si
critiquer la nécessité nécessitait le
retour à l'état d'urgence comment
conciliez-vous l'impératif de continuité
des soins et le respect de la loi je
rappelle qu'ici au sénat nous avions
rejetée par exemple un amendement qui
visait à permettre de suspendre
l'obligation en cas de besoin de
services que nous estimions de nature à
d inciter au respect de la vaccination
ensuite les recommandations de la haute
autorité de santé concernant l'évolution
du schéma vaccinal ont notamment conduit
le gouvernement proposait le soignant
une dose de rappel
comptez-vous dans les mois à venir
adapter le schéma de vaccination
obligatoire et rendre nécessaire voire
obligatoire la troisième dose je
souligne d'ailleurs que la commission
des affaires sociales avait choisi de
dissocier le schéma vaccinal nécessaires
aux patients terre de celui permettant
de satisfaire à l'obligation vaccinale
justement en vue d'anticiper la
possibilité de telles évolutions
troisième question si je souhaiterais
vous interroger sur les modifications
que vous apportez à l'article 13 de la
loi du 5 août concernant les modalités
de contrôle du respect de l'obligation
vaccinale vous revendiquez à cet article
une dérogation très générales au secret
médical sans viser précisément ni dans
l'étude d'impact ni encore moins dans le
dispositif et personnes qui pourraient
être amenées comment l'anticipent à
accéder aux fichiers ces vaccins quelle
conception avez-vous de la protection du
secret médical quand il concerne
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 nous voulons
que le dispositif fonctionne mais la
simplicité opérationnelle ne justifie
pas tout si une dérogation peut
s'entendre pour les personnes soumises à
l'obligation vaccinale comment
pouvons-nous ensemble mieux la définir
et ne pas laisser penser que par ce
biais et si vaccin devient une base de
données médicales en accès beaucoup trop
ouvert
sur les questions de droit du travail
le texte contient plusieurs habilitation
à légiférer par ordonnances qui sont
formulées de manière trop large ou dont
les objectifs ne sont pas suffisamment
précis en particulier quelle adaptation
supplémentaire de niveau législatif
pourrait-il être nécessaire de prévoir
sur le complément employeurs aux
indemnités journalières maladie alors
qu'un régime d'exception est inscrit de
manière pérenne dans le code du travail
et permet déjà aux gouvernements de
déroger par décret aux conditions de
versement de cette indemnité
complémentaire en cas de crise sanitaire
sur l'activité partielle de longue durée
ne vous paraît-il pas possible d'écrire
une disposition en dur dans le projet de
loi plutôt que de demander une
habilitation vous savez qu'ici au sénat
nous n'aimons pas beaucoup les
ordonnances
et mu qui
revient d'autres mères
où la situer où la situation est
particulièrement grave merci madame la
présidente merci monsieur le ministre
en complément parce que mes philippe bas
et pascale gruny ont posé juste tirait
l'essentiel des questions mais moi
monsieur le ministre voudrait que vous
nous expliquiez au fond quel est
l'intérêt du pass annie terre sur une
population qui est vaccinée à un niveau
très élevé il y avait il y avait deux
objectifs à ce passe sanitaire que j'en
rappelle nous avons
la première fois approuvé un
pouce et à la vaccination par une
obligation vaccinale déguisé bon on
aurait pu avoir une obligation vaccinale
franches mais passons une obligation
vaccinale déguisés qui a marché qui a
très bien fonctionné tout le monde
connaît les chiffres du nombre de
français qui se sont vaccinés et
deuxièmement on pouvait espérer parce
qu'on avait pas de données à 6 avec
l'expérience qu'ils pouvaient nous le
dire une réduction de la circulation
virale or sur cet aspect là le pass
sanitaire n'a pas démontré
d'efficacité très nette ça a été rappelé
par le conseil scientifique vient d'être
appelé par le rapporteur vous avancez
une donnée de 30 % de la circulation
mais j'ai cru comprendre dans vos propos
vous vous anglo biais les gestes
barrière dans cette donnée là en tout
état de cause c'est un effet qui est qui
est faible sur la réduction la
circulation virale ce n'est pas un motif
de satisfaction c'est un constat et donc
quel est l'objectif de maintien du pass
sanitaires sur une population très
vaccinez vous nous avez dit on ne peut
pas viser d'écrasement du virus mais je
ne sais pas ce qu'est cette notion
exactement d'écrasement il ya soit notre
pays cherchent une stratégie zéro
coville ce que personne ne propose et
voilà ça paraît tout à fait hors de
portée
soit on vise et je voudrais savoir si
c'est votre stratégie de ramener le
virus à un bruit de fond avec des
petites récurrence climatique ou autres
voilà et un bruit de fond un virus qui
provoque un bruit de fond avec des
récurrences c'est absorbable par le
système de santé premièrement et
deuxièmement ça ne nécessite aucune
mesure exorbitante du droit commun donc
si
voilà ici c'est bien ça la stratégie on
a du mal à comprendre ce que vous
attendez de la prolongation du pass
sanitaires
d'autant que
sur les mesures en ce qui concerne
incitation à la vaccination la dernière
mesure dont vous espériez en effet la
fin de la gratuité totale des tests par
la fin du remboursement mais la fin la
gratuité totale il semblerait que à j +
11 elle n'est pas produit d'effet mais
vous nous direz si vous voyez une
reprise nette de la vaccination depuis
la fin de cette gratuité totale des
tests voilà donc la question vraiment
c'est pour vous quel niveau d'épidémie
légitime cette restriction parce que
c'est une restriction liberté le pass
sanitaires et pour quelle efficacité
tués
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
trois observations et question d'abord
monsieur mines dans votre tour d'europe
vous avez vous est passé rapidement sur
l'espagne qui pourtant malgré l'absence
de passé et a dans ce pays a un taux de
vaccination supérieur à la france et a
priori une contamination inférieur
deuxième
deuxième intervention
depuis que les thèses sont rendus
payants
quelques ailes
payant ou non remboursés quel que
constatez-vous sur
la défilent à la lame à l'appréciation
du taux d'incidence sur la baisse du
nombre de tests effectués donc pas qui
pourrait entraîner la baisse du nombre
de tests positifs et si on les ramène un
chiffre de cent mille habitants on
pourrait imaginer que ce chiffre baisse
artificiellement du fait que moins de
tests sont pratiqués
troisième et dernière d'animaux
la cnil de manière de manière régulière
dénonce le risque d'accoutumance au
passé ni terre ce risque d'agonie
monuments nous le constatons tout le
monde a dit que le pass était temporaire
force est de constater qu'il s'installe
dans nos vies quotidiennes comme un
élément courant et je veux bien que j'en
sois un un pourfendeur
beaucoup de français se le sont
appropriés et revendique cette
imbrication exemple finalement ça ne
nous gêne pas moi avec mon ma lecture
demande de la cnil depuis sept ans je
peux vous assurer que c'est exactement
ce que nous craignons et donc qu'est ce
que vous entendez faire pour que on
lutte contre la coutume ans au contrôle
social sur la base d'éléments de santé
mais c'est le ministre ensuite nous
aurons deux autres question monsieur le
ministre
d'abord je voulais remercier les
sénatrices et sénateurs qui se sont
exprimés qui qui
pour la qualité de vie avec que nous
pouvons avoir à mon tour je suis pas sûr
de mon rôle mais je voulais vous
remercier parce que je me souviens du
dernier texte que nous avons eues adopté
effet je leur apporte en bas s'en
souvient aussi bien que moi les
conditions dans lesquelles il vous a été
demandé de l'adopter de l'urgence qu'il
y avait à l'impérieuse l'impérieuse
nécessité qu'il y avait trouvé un accord
et le sénat était en responsabilité
présent et je tenais à le souligner
et je me réjouis à nouveau de pouvoir
débattre et discuter avec vous et la
qualité des questions montrent que vous
avez une connaissance extrêmement film
et un suivi très très rapprochées toutes
ces questions est ce qu'on peut
quantifier l'impact du tube du pass
sanitaires sur la circulation du virus
moi je vous poser une autre question
est ce qu'on peut quantifier l'impact du
masque dans la pile dans l'épidémie
est-ce qu'on peut quantifier l'impact du
gel hydroalcoolique ça répond aussi une
question qu'on m'a posée manama
sénatrice grigny dans l'épidémie il est
difficile d'approché à la contamination
près quel est l'impact de ces différents
outils pour autant vous savez qu'à la
théorie eyal empirique lots l'empirique
c'est à dire l'observer nous permettent
d'attester que certains outils sont
fonctionnels efficace voire
indispensable dans la période épidémique
pandémique que nous connaissons avec le
co vide certaines approximations j'en ai
parlé de salaire dans l' intervention
liminaire montre que le passé aurait pu
permettre de réduire de 25 à 30% des
contaminations parce qu'ils protègent
des établissements qui sont des lieux
très propice à la création de clusters
quand vous identifier et que vous gardez
en pleine vague épidémique des
restaurants ouverts et que vous avez une
chute drastique du nombre de clusters et
donc d'extension de contamination issus
de deux clusters dans des restaurants
alors que les restaurants ont pu rester
ouverts qu'est-ce qui est quelle était
la différence était pas sanitaires donc
c'est un si vous arrivez approximer
avoisiner l'impact d'une mesure et cette
mesure passe est quelque chose qui pose
y pas ailleurs vous l'avez souligné à
juste titre monsieur le sénateur bas
vous avez dit quand on a mis le passé on
était déjà en diminution etc je vous
ferai remarquer vous pourrez regarder
c'est assez intéressant et en même temps
assez compréhensible à chaque fois qu'on
a mis en place des mesures de gestion y
compris d'ailleurs des mesures de
confinement au moment où ces mesures se
mettait en place il y avait avant même
qu'on puisse en mesurer la pleine
efficacité et une petite réduction
pourquoi parce que vous
quand vous sonnez l' alerte quand vous
faites qu'on appelle en affreux
anglicismes un wake up call pour dire
attention la situation est grave on va
devoir agir vous avez immédiatement une
adaptation des comportements de la même
manière quand vous êtes dans une
épidémie qui vivotent et qui fait moins
parler d'elle vous avez une très intense
au relâchement relâchement sans doute du
contrôle de passe dans certains endroits
de samrée de et de son respect
relâchement des gestes barrières madame
la sénatrice raison pour laquelle nous
avons lancé une nouvelle campagne de
communication nationale pour rappeler
l'importance des gestes barrières du
port du masque du gel hydroalcoolique de
la distanciation sociale pour des
fictions des situations les plus à
risque et donc ces questions
comportementales sont à prendre en
compte vous avez posé des questions sur
les risques du virus chez les personnes
vaccinées d'abord à chaque fois qu'on a
eu un nouveau variant est le delta n'a
pas fait exception à la règle il ya eu
une pathogénicité donc une dangerosité
intrinsèque au virus un peu plus
importantes à dire que là mais le virus
quand ils varient devient un peu plus
dangereux et peut créer statistiquement
plus de cas graves
quand on est vaccinés on est protégé à
plus de 90% compte et qui aggravent
c'est très bien mais c'est pas du 100 %
vous avez des gens qui bien que vacciner
même si c'est beaucoup plus rare peuvent
présenter des situations des cas graves
or plus le virus circule
plus vous allez avoir de risque d'être
contaminé que vous soyez vacciner ou non
même si la protection conférée par la
vaccination est réelle et forte vous
avez aussi des gens qui peuvent être
vaccinés mais immunodéprimés et donc une
fragilité d'un système immunitaire qui
peut les exposer à des risques de forme
grave vous avez des gens qui sont très
fragiles très âgées raison pour laquelle
nous faisons les rappels de vaccination
qui bien que vacciner peuvent être
exposés à des risques de formes graves
et vous avez des gens qui peuvent faire
des copies de long on manque encore
d'études on manque encore d'études
suffisamment fine sur la possibilité de
présenter des séquelles à distance même
quand on n'a pas eu une forme grave mais
qu'on humains cohabitent symptomatique
conçoit vacciner ou non donc on reste
dans une logique de prudence qui est
tout à fait compréhensible mais poser la
question des traitements il ya encore un
affreux games nous offre aux anglicismes
c'est ce qu'on appelle un game 'changer
c'est le mot le mip ira bien le menu qui
ravirent est une molécule anti viral qui
et commercialisée désormais ou presque
et qui a montré que lorsqu'elle a été
prise de façon précoce chez des gens qui
sont symptomatiques et c'est un
traitement oral cette fois-ci par
l'injection sur sept jours en comprimés
et bien ils pouvaient réduire de l'ordre
de 50% le risque de formes graves
imaginez que nous ayons eu à la place de
traitements non fonctionnel que certains
distribué comme on distribuait des
bonbons haribo hélas imaginez que nous
ayons à l'époque un traitement antiviral
qui réduisait de 50% le nombre de cas
graves imaginez l'impact sanitaire dans
notre pays au cours de la 1ère et la
2ème vague on aurait eu beaucoup moins
de décès est beaucoup moins de cas
graves la science parfois prendre un peu
plus de temps que ce qu'on souhaiterait
mais la science a permis d'identifier
des premiers traitements probant
démontré dans les exposants dans des
études cliniques vérifier relu par des
comités internationaux et le traitement
le menu pire à dire la france en a
commandé s'est positionné très tôt en
précommande qui j'ai confirmé les
commandes cinquante mille doses de ce
médicament vont être livrés à la france
a compté des derniers jours de novembre
des premiers jours de décembre c'est à
dire dès que les traitements sortiront
des chaînes de production nous aurons
également dans les semaines qui suivront
dans les mois qui suivront de nouveau
traitement par anticorps monoclonaux
passé avec la france on dispose
aujourd'hui mais ces traitements en
parle anticorps monoclonaux se renforce
encore deviennent de plus en plus
efficaces et le cocktail des deux chez
les gens qui sont à risque de faire des
formes graves pourraient réduire très
fortement le risque de faire des cas
graves qui serait forcément une très
bonne nouvelle puisque vaccination en
plus traitement antiviral plus anticorps
monoclonaux égale impacts sanitaires
bien moindre et ça nous mettrait aussi
entre guillemets à l'abri en cas de
vague épidémique lit un nouveau variant
dont on ignore encore les dégâts qui
pourraient provoquer dans notre pays les
poser la question du plafond de
vaccination est ce qui nous reste encore
des gens qui ne sont pas vaccinés qu'on
pourraient vacciner nous on part du
principe que 92% de la population
vaccinable devrait pouvoir être vacciné
c'est je dirais le la campagne idéal de
vaccination à l'échelle de la population
c'est en toute façon on est déjà en
dehors de tous les records je vous
rappelle qu'on est bien au delà de ce
que les enquêtes d'opinion ont montré
comme intention vaccinale pays et donc
ça veut dire qu'il nous reste encore
environ deux millions de personnes dont
on se dit d'après les études
qualitatives qui sont faites par les
sondages et ce sont des gens qui
attendent et qui ne sont pas opposés à
l'idée se faire vacciner et donc ces
deux millions personnes là nous allons
les chercher par tout médecin pharmacien
vous savez que les libéraux peuvent
désormais commander autant de freezer
qu'ils veulent et faire des injections
autant qu'ils le veulent que les
pharmaciens sont fondés à préparer des
seringues monodoses pour que les
médecins puissent avoir une seringue
monodoses dans leur cabinet pour
vacciner à l'emporte-pièce un patient
qui viendraient qui ne seraient pas
encore vaccinés qu'il serrait pourquoi
pas les infirmiers l'échidné message à
tout le monde vaccine on a lancé des
campagnes une instruction
interministérielle est parti
encore récemment pour mobiliser tous les
acteurs de terrain et réorienter
certaines lignes de vaccination de
centres de vaccination pour faire du
aller vers en ruralité dans les
quartiers populaires des villes là où il
ya encore des gens qu'on peut vacciner
on est à plus de 51 millions on sera je
l'espère à 52 millions de primo
vaccination pénétrant décembre jeu qu'on
voit monsieur le sénateur shelby qui m'a
posé la question mais on voit que la fin
de la gratuité complète des tests s'est
accompagnée d'un petit rebond primo
vaccination
on est remonté de l'or de 40000 à 50000
primo vaccination par jour ça compte
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ça
compte parce que cinquante mille par
jour ça nous fait du 300 milles par
semaine ça veut dire quant à moi c'est
un million de français qui n'étaient pas
vaccinés qui le sont donc si on continue
sur ce rythme c'est c'est important
parce que un million de non vaccinés qui
sont vaccinées c'est un impact sanitaire
qui est qui est épargnée et c'est un
risque de deux mesures de gestion ou de
confinement qui s'éloigne encore
davantage
l'enjeu des rappels il est majeur
il faut que les personnes âgées que les
personnes avec des maladies chroniques
ou les personnes pour une seule dose de
johnson puisse et les soignants puisse
avoir cette cette dose de rappel les
statistiques ne sont pas excellentes
mais ne sont pas non plus mauvaises si
je prends la situation des plus de 65
ans et qu'on regarde six mois après la
dernière dose on était à 55 % qui ont
déjà reçu leur appel et quand on regarde
un mois plus tard à sept mois on l'aide
à des statistiques j'ai pas encore les
derniers chiffres ne pas vous les donner
mais
on sait déjà que c'est nettement
supérieur cela dit il faut qu'on aille
davantage proposé de rappel aux
personnes quand windows de john seine
aux personnes qui sont atteintes de
comorbidité vous avez posé la question
de l'intégration potentielle dans le
pass des doses de rappel pour les
publics les plus fragiles ça fait
l'objet de réflexions et ça fait l'objet
désormais d'une saisine des autorités
sanitaires compétentes c'est à dire le
comité d'orientation des stratégies
vaccinales la haute autorité de santé et
le conseil scientifique est ce qu'il ya
lieu ou non de demander pour conserver
le bénéfice de son passe lorsqu'on est
particulièrement fragile d'attester du
fait d'avoir reçu la dose de rappel je
n'ai pas la réponse mais j'ai posé la
question pour la sénatrice grünig
m'avait aussi posé la question de
l'obligation vaccinale en territoires
ultramarins c'est une situation
éminemment complexe une vague épidémique
sans précédent des dégâts hospitalier
majeur 2500 soignants depuis la mi-août
qui ont quitté la métropole pour aller
prêter main-forte alors que la grande
outre mer dans des conditions parfois
difficiles y compris des conditions
d'accueil qui peuvent être parfois
difficile beaucoup de fausses
informations circulent beaucoup de peurs
non fondées alors que la peur fondée
elle c'est la peur du virus et la vague
épidémique une protection de la
population qui n'est pas suffisante et
une protection des soignants qui n'est
pas suffisante ce que j'ai demandé c'est
que la loi s'applique et je le redis la
loi de la république doit s'appliquer
sur tout le territoire de république il
en va aussi de la crédibilité de la part
de l'état on tient compte madame la
sénatrice tout de même de la réalité
sanitaire de la 2 je dirais de la charge
de travail qui repose aujourd'hui sur
les directeurs d'hôpitaux et sur les
équipes médicales et soignantes et j'ai
demandé à ce que la loi s'applique mais
qu'elle s'applique avec je dirais le bon
jugement et je préfère qu au lieu de
travailler à l'échelle de tout un
établissement du jour au lendemain on a
une équipe par équipe unité par unité
service par service convaincre les
derniers réticents et prendre des
mesures de suspension là où c'est
nécessaire j'ai annoncé une médiation
qui va pouvoir partir et qui va aller
sur place en martinique pour établir les
conditions d'un dialogue serein
l'ensemble des parties prenantes pour
que la loi s'applique dans de bonnes
conditions et surtout qu'on fasse
progresser la vaccination par ailleurs
j'ai une donnée intéressante n'était pas
encore sortie pour vous qu une question
qui m'a été posée plusieurs fois
qu'advient-il des soignants en métropole
ou en outre-mer qui ont été suspendues
faute d'être vacciné et bien des
premières remontées dont je dispose les
deux tiers d'entre eux les deux tiers
des soignants suspendus sont revenus au
travail une fois vacciner les deux tiers
c'est bien c'est bien on est donc un
taux de couverture vaccinale des
salariés des établissements sanitaires
et médico sociaux qui est extrêmement
élevé et un taux de suspension et de
démission qui est extrêmement faible
c'est donc je le dis et vous avez été en
responsabilité vous avez accompagné
l'obligation vaccinale des soignants
c'était une obligation qui s'applique
dans de bonnes conditions sur le
territoire national
sur la question de la dérogation au
secret médical et de l'ess et de l'accès
au logiciel est si vague le principe
posé c'est que l'établissement chargé du
contrôle peut connaître le statut
vaccinal de l'agent s'agissant des
établissements de santé et le cadre sera
précédée par un décret en conseil d'état
après avis de la cnil donc ne vous
inquiétez pas il n'y a pas de on n'a pas
du tout l'intention de donner accès à et
sivac à qui que ce soit ça passera
toujours par un intermédiaire et c'est
uniquement pour permettre aux gens qui
doivent faire respecter une obligation
de la faire respecter dans de bonnes
conditions une dérogation par exemple
ont laissé chez les soignants qu'on
connaît depuis des années des années sur
l'hépatite b sur la diphtérie tétanos la
polio est une obligation de pouvoir
contrôler le respect de l'obligation
vaccinale par les employeurs donc on est
dans quelque chose qui hors droit commun
mais qui aident mais qui existent déjà
dans le droit est utilisé depuis des
décennies dans être dans notre feuille
sur le droit du travail j'ai bien
entendu votre votre objection sur elle
le
bémol que vous mettez sur leur donne ans
néanmoins sachez qu'il s'agit d'
uniquement de dispositions favorables
salariés uniquement dispositions
favorables aux salariés pour éviter des
suspensions ou dj ou de salaire dans des
conditions qui nécessiterait la
fermeture d'entreprises où le recours au
chômage partiel et donc le gouvernement
fait le choix de la réactivité de la
flexibilité de manière à pouvoir décider
au jour le jour s'il était besoin de
mesures permettant la conservation des
droits pour les salariés ce ne sont en
aucun cas des mesures qui rognerait sur
leurs droits or si on était dans un
mécanisme classique il faudra alors
concertés l'ensemble des parties
prenantes ce qui ferait perdre un mois
et je crois que les français depuis les
bus la crise sanitaire nous son gré de
leur avoir permis de percevoir sans
délai les revenus qui leur étaient dues
et ne pas avoir de suspension de revenus
parce que là ce serait évidemment une
catastrophe pour eux quel est l'objectif
du pass thani terre quand tout le monde
est vaccinée
c'est une très bonne question que me
poser le sénateur juillet
jekyll non mais si 100 % des gens sont
vaccinés le pass alité en impulsant ce
que je fais par des visions tout le
monde est là vous avez encore vous avez
encore 10% de la population vaccinable
qui n'est pas vacciné et donc j'avais
encore 10% des gens qui n'ont pas le
pass imaginez un établi imaginer une
circulation du virus mais tant qu'on
soit à vingt ou trente mille cas par
jour dans le pays d'accord imaginez que
vous ayez un établissement recevant du
public qui réunit 300 personnes qui n'en
qui parce qu'il est sous passe sanitaire
n'engendre plus le port systématique du
masque statistiquement vous aurez une
chance sur je peux vous faire un camion
comme ça mais imaginons une chance sur x
que quelqu'un de non vaccinés est
contagieux soient présents dans les
établissements recevant du public et
donc statistiquement un risque de
contamination d'autres personnes autour
qui peuvent créer des chaînes de
contamination donc c'est ceinture et
bretelles je voudrais vous faire une
métaphore monsieur le député monsieur le
sénateur pardonnez moi imaginez que vous
ayez des voitures automatiques qui soit
dont on nous disent qu'elles sont
parfaitement sûre et qu'elles ne
provoquent plus d' accidents de la route
est ce que pour autant dès les premiers
mois vous avez retiré la ceinture vous
allez à conserver en me disant lusage
nous dira lusage nous dira si le fait
que ces pilote automatique soit
sécurisée nous permettent de retirer le
port de la ceinture obligatoire ben on a
on est dans cette logique là on n'a pas
suffisamment de recul à ce stade pour
pouvoir nous priver d'un outil qui est
fonctionnel accepté par les gens qui est
très bien accepté par des gens avec le
recul monsieur le sénateur bassi est
très bien accepté par les gens
aujourd'hui je les enquêtes d'opinion
montrent que les français sont
favorables aux pass sanitaire dans leur
majorité parce qu'ils ont compris ça les
protéger et que ça n'encense anna
rejoindrait pas d'origine gardoise qui
veut pas dire qu'on veut le maintenir
dans la durée ça veut pas dire qu'on
veut maintenir le pas dans la durée
c'est pas un outil avec lequel nous
allons vivre pendant des années mais ça
veut dire que dans la situation dans la
situation pandémique que nous
connaissons les français ont compris que
le pass à lithaire avait permis de ne
pas fermer les bars ne pas fermer les
restaurants ne pas fermer les salles les
théâtres de ne pas fermer les cinémas
que nous avons connu une meilleure
saison touristique en 2021 qu'en 2019
avant même la pandémie et que l'activité
sociale économique culturelle et
sportive a pu reprendre dans notre pays
et les français je crois dans leur
grande majorité ont compris qu'en
prenant une vague épidémique comme la
vague du variante delta si nous n'avions
pas une passe nous aurions été contraint
de fermer un certain nombre
d'établissements et ça ne veulent plus
de fermeture donc aujourd'hui le pass
permet cette garantie l'a1 quand nous
aurons la certitude que le niveau de
vaccination de leur en plus nécessaire
nous supprimons 2 lorsque la circulation
virale sera suffisamment atténuées pour
que nous n'ayons pu besoin de contrôler
qui est vacciné qui ne l'est pas nous le
supprimerons je redis notre volonté
farouche de nous prie de nous passer de
cet outil dès que nous pourrons nous en
passer croyez sur mon engagement en
engagement sur ce sujet
qu'elle est en fait la stratégie de
l'écrasement pour le sénateur jonnier
qui pose la question au fond qu'est ce
qu'on vise avec ma stratégie il ya
plusieurs possibilités si on en restait
avec un variant comme celui ci avec son
niveau de contagiosité et son niveau de
pathogénicité est-ce qu'il faut procéder
à des rappels de vaccination chez qui
est tous les combien aujourd'hui on sait
que c'est les gens qui sont fragiles par
le rajout par leur maladie et dont le
système immunitaire ne garde pas la
mémoire suffisamment longtemps il faut
un rappel à six mois pour les gens qui
sont plus jeunes aujourd'hui n'y a pas
de recommandations il ya qui sera utile
le faire
parce qu'on sait on sait que le système
immunitaire et plus
on sait que le système immunitaire les
plus matures peut-être qu'avec
l'observer des données à 10 mois 11 mois
12 mois si les données nous montrent que
l'immunité s'affaiblit chez les gens
plus jeunes dans ce cas là on sera amené
à dire aux gens il vous faut un rappel
aujourd'hui ce n'était pas le cas et
mais ces données ne montre pas mais que
nous permettrait une vaccination massive
dans la durée et contre ce qu vide qui
va pas disparaître de lui même de la
planète eh bien ça il ya plusieurs issue
favorable la première issue favorable
c'est une mutation du virus parce qu'ils
n'arrivent plus trop à circuler il est
contraint il mute il devient peut-être
contagieux mais inactif c'est-à-dire
n'entraînant pas de symptômes et donc on
vit avec comme on vit avec et des
milliers et des milliers et des milliers
de virus je rappelle qu'il ya plus de
virus dans une cuillère à soupe d'eau de
mer qui lie à d'européens sur le
continent européen donc on peut rendre
ce virus entre guillemets inactifs par
lui-même grâce à la vaccination qui fait
qu'il n'a plus le voit d'échappatoire
l'autre possibilité c'est que ce soit un
virus qui reviennent de manière
récurrente par vaguelettes et non plus
par vagues et qui ne soit pas plus
dangereux que d'autres virus qu'on
connaît dans le pays comme la grippe par
exemple donc ça c'est la vaccination
qu'il permettra à ce qu'il faut faire
des rappels ou non tout ça il n'y a que
le temps qui nous permettra de le savoir
ça ce sont les scénarios qui sont
positifs favorables scénarios négatifs
auquel personne ne veut penser
évidemment c'est celui d'une nouvelle
mutation avec un échappement immunitaire
au vaccin une nouvelle circulation etc
etc star aujourd'hui tout nous laisse à
penser que nous avons désormais la
maîtrise de l'épidémie grâce aux outils
dont nous disposons et ces outils là
nous savons que nous en aurons besoin
dans les mois à venir et pas dans les
semaines à venir c'est l'objet de ce
projet de loi que veut dire disons d'où
les choses en franchise on met la
politique de côté on met la question des
élections de côté on se dit juste est ce
qu'il ya une chance est ce qu'il ya une
chance pour que dans trois mois la
situation soit différente aujourd'hui
la réponse est non est ce que nous avons
aujourd'hui trouver les bons outils qui
permettent d'avoir un niveau d'
équilibre entre les contraintes et les
libertés la réponse est oui est ce que
nous avons su montrer depuis six mois
que désormais même si
mik il n'y a pas d'impact sanitaire
majeur dans notre pays la réponse est
oui est-ce qu'il faut nous désarmer dans
les mois à venir la réponse est non
dernière question mais il beaucoup de
questions pousser mais c'est intéressant
la fin de la gratuité des tests je les
dis ça fait monter un peu la
primovaccination et on n'a pas du tout
sûr perdu les suivis de l'épidémie on
n'a pas casser le thermomètre déjà on
est à plus de 2 millions de tests par
semaine s'il veut dire qu'on est dans la
moyenne haute européenne et d'ailleurs
on n'est plus dans le le comme rejoint
la moyenne européenne en arrive
davantage comparer avec nos voisins
ensuite on a pris vous savez un point au
moment juste avant la guerre de la fin
de la gratuité des tests on avait le
nombre de tests et le nombre de cas
positifs ensuite on enregistré la baisse
du nombre de tests environ 30 % sur la
semaine qui a suivi et donc on a
enregistré une baisse du taux
d'incidence qu'on avait et qu'on avait
anticipé et une semaine plus tard on met
un nouveau point sur la courbe on trace
et on reprend la perspective de
l'épidémie donc on absolument pas perdu
les outils de mesure de l'épidémie et on
est à un niveau de tests encore une fois
qui est très ambitieux et je rappelle
que des tests sont gratuits pour tout le
monde sauf si vous n'êtes pas vacciné
vous n'avez pas d'ordonnancé ne voulait
pas qu'un contact que vous ne participez
pas une opération dépistage collectif
que vous n'allez pas dans un barnum et
vous n'êtes pas appeler ni par
l'assurance maladie ni par 10 par la
grèce on a quand même à garder un niveau
de sécurisation les outils de mesure
d'épidémie qui est bien plus élevé que
chez n'importe lequel de nos voisins je
vous remercie chez les joueurs nous
avons encore plusieurs questions madame
de la gontrie plus madame bof anti de ça
puis monsieur n'à richard puis monsieur
martin devriez et probablement sur le
questeur bas
questions courtes de l'eau a besoin
de deux questions j'ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'intérêt
je pas sûr d'avoir tout compris mais bon
du coup je deux questions courtes je
n'ai rien entendu
pour que vous expliquer pourquoi le 31
juillet je m'explique tous ici
tous ici nous disons nous sommes dans
des groupes parlementaires différents
nous soucier gens jusqu'à fin février
jamais les textes successifs vous l'avez
rappelé on en a eu 11 non prévus des
durées si longue donc
je n'ai pas entendu une seule fois un
argument rationnel
qui explique pourquoi vous voulez aller
au-delà de fin février premièrement
deuxièmement je vous ai écoutés sur la
question de la dose de rappel et de la
validité du pass sanitaire est ce que
j'ai bien entendu qu'en fait vous n'en
savez rien c'est à dire que vous avez
dit j'ai posé la question
mais vous n'avez pas la réponse donc à
l'heure où nous parlons nous nous sommes
bien d'accord que vous ne savez pas dire
si le pass sanitaire restera valide
dans quelles conditions en fonction de
la troisième de la dose de rappel je
suis pas clair voulait que je reformule
non ma question c'est votre imprécisions
et votre incapacité à répondre de
manière claire sur ce point
oui mais si vous savez
si possible on pose des questions on
répond après parce que le temps tourne
je répète vous avez dit tout à l'heure
et j ai noté j'ai posé la question
d'accord donc jeu ce qui nous importe
aussi ici c'est de comprendre comment ça
va marcher et donc cette affaire de
passes sanitaires indépendamment du fait
de savoir si on est pour si on est
contre et etc comment est ce que vous
allez incrémenté la question de la dose
de rappel puisque vous avez dit tout à
l'heure j'ai posé la question
oui merci par ailleurs monsieur le
ministre nous ne sommes pas à l'école
donc je fais ce que je veux pendant que
vous parlez mais pas ailleurs je peux
vous poser en prévision sur vos
imprécisions sous la halle et ben bof
entier
c'est le ministre on apprend mais
peut-être en informations étaient
erronées et dans ces conditions pour
vous me le direz mais permettez moi de
poursuivre on apprend que le pass and i
ter ne sera pas obligatoire pour les
meetings politiques
or s'il ya lieu de libre circulation et
de prolifération du virus c'est bien
quand même dans le meeting politique en
même temps en même temps on sait que le
passé maintenant obligatoire aux enfants
qui veulent s'instruire sagement dans
les bibliothèques chacun assis à sa
place en dehors de toute condition
d'entassement
selon les statistiques officielles
là aussi vous être je me trompe 30 % des
enfants de 12 à 18 ans ne sont pas
vaccinés et ne dispose pas de pass à
lithaire alors on peut se poser la
question pourquoi ne sont ils pas
vacciner peut-être parce que pendant des
mois le discours officiel a été de
marteler que la vaccination des jeunes
étaient inutiles voire contre-productive
avant une soudaine volte face en début
d'été donc nous savons aujourd'hui que
comme le pass est obligatoire pour
accéder dans les espaces culturels et
même sportif je crois
nous constatons qu aujourd'hui 30 %
presque un tiers des jeunes seront deux
bannis des lieux d'intelligente se fait
ça c'est ma déduction elle est peut-être
un peu rapide dans ma question est ce à
dire monsieur le ministre que le meeting
politique mérite plus de considération
que des enfants qui souhaitent
s'instruire merci de votre réponse
précise
merci madame monsieur larry charles mais
là il revient sur le sujet de
l'incorporation de la troisième dose
dans le pass
la question dont vous attendez la
réponse des experts et est-ce qu'il est
pertinent
de faire de la troisième dose une
condition du maintien du pass sanitaires
pour un set mon public
je trouve cette question légitime et
nous allons la réponse dans quelques
jours elle sera public le permis sera
débattu par tout le monde c'est
simplement ce qui m'a surpris c'est
quand vous disiez
le
cette incorporation cette inclusion la
troisième dose dans le pass sera
applicable en fonction des pathologies
des gens
si on dit les plus de 65 ans les moins
de 65 ça c'est déjà dans le sait déjà
dont les données du passe donc à aucun
problème pour dire la la troisième dose
devient indispensable pour avoir le pas
si vous avez plus de 65 ans mais si
c'est
aussi elle devient indispensable si vous
êtes en surpoids
je ne comprends pas d'où on tire cette
donnée
applicables à chaque individu sur son
carnet de vaccination
donc je préférerais que vous nous donner
une réponse un peu par oui ou par non
est-ce que
on a les données
utilisables dans des conditions pratique
est légale pour bondir modules et
l'inclusion ou non
la troisième dose pour le maintien du
pass
si monsieur richard mais chez martin
devriez qui était en visio mais j'ai
l'impression que la marque elle est là
et la mairie merci monsieur le président
merci monsieur le ministre pour vos
réponses très claires merci aussi
d'avoir rappelé plusieurs fois parce
qu'on a tendance à l'oublier que c'est
une pandémie est pas une crise française
et que donc c'est le camp des mines les
tous les ressorts que l'on peut utiliser
pour la combattre relève de sujets qui
peuvent être sur le temps long et
parfois sur beaucoup d'incertitudes une
question à travers tout ça dans les
décisions qui avaient été prises cet été
et même avant il y avait la possibilité
pour les médecins généralistes d'accéder
aux fichiers de leur patientèle qui ne
seraient pas vaccinés il semblerait que
malheureusement beaucoup de médecins ne
l'utilisent pas ou ce soit le résultat
soit très faible qu'est-ce que vous avez
des statistiques à ce sujet là et est ce
qu'on peut imaginer des moyens pour
accélérer ce processus parce que je
pense que la meilleure solution pour
aller vers en particulier les personnes
les plus âgées passent par les médecins
généralistes
un grand merci si monsieur bah merci
monsieur le président je disais tout à
l'heure monsieur le ministre c'est le
moment de vous poser des questions ce
n'est pas encore le moment du débat mais
je veux réagir sur un point vous nous
dites rien ne permet de penser que la
situation sera différente ou 28 février
de ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui mais enfin
monsieur le ministre la situation n'a
cessé d'évoluer de mois en mois la
situation est-elle la même aujourd'hui
qu'au mois de juillet la réponse est
évidemment non il ya des transformation
très profonde du contexte
épidémiologique il y a des éléments vous
les avez relevé vous même s'agissant des
nouvelles molécules qui sont sur le
marché qui sont nouveaux les effets de
la vaccination doivent encore être
mesuré dans le temps bien sûr que oui la
situation dans trois mois ne sera pas la
même qu'aujourd'hui est ce que nous dit
nous c'est tout simplement que nous
voulons non pas vous priver de moyens
d'action mais décidée en fonction d'un
contexte si oui ou non nous les
prolongeront et c'est ce que nous avons
toujours fait il n'y a pas de raison que
le sénat adopte une ligne différente de
celle qui correspond à sa cohérence
profonde c'est juste ça mais je crois
pas qu'on puisse vous laisser dire
monsieur le ministre que la situation
sera la même en février car s'il ya une
chose qui est bien certaine c'est
qu'elle sera différente
mais c'est le ministre juste une seconde
je voudrais rebondir sur la la sphère de
la troisième zone parce qu'on la
troisième dose puisqu'on m'a dit qu'on
pouvait pas l'intégrer immédiatement
qu'il fallait un délai pour pour
l'intégrer au pass sanitaire
comment est-ce que vous expliquer ce
délai et voilà donc sur la troisième dos
on m'a dit qu'on pouvait pas d'intégrer
immédiatement pas sanitaire qu'il
fallait un certain temps si on intègre
et tout de suite ça risquait de
d'abord il restait d'avoir un
dysfonctionnement en tous les cas du
logiciel ou du passé ni terre donc est
ce que c'est bien réglée est ce qu'il
faut vraiment attendre avant d'intégrer
opa sanitaire sur ministre vous jeu au
risque d'être désagréable à présent je
ne serai pas et quand madame la
sénatrice dit jamais les textes non
prévue de durer si longue
les chiffres sont têtus
sénatrice on a déjà créé proroger le
régime de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
pour 12 mois puis pour neuf mois on a
déjà prorogé le cadre dsi qu'ovide pour
neuf mois donc le texte que nous
présentons aujourd'hui le prolonge de
sept mois et demi donc quand laquelle
assertion qui vont c'est à dire qu'on
n'a jamais projet de façon aussi pour
une durée aussi longue est factuellement
fausse est battue en brèche par les
propres votes émis par les sénateurs eux
mêmes et à plusieurs reprises
la question qui porte sur le droit
électoral là aussi mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs je vous rappelle que il la
trouve pas lui trouver un équilibre
entre les deux chambres sur le champ
d'application du pass thani terre et
vous avez souhaité dans votre grande
sagesse que ce champ d'application se
réservait aux strictes activités dites
de loisirs j'étais là je me souviens
bien des débats que nous avions à
l'époque le conseil constitutionnel dans
sa grande sagesse des oc a donc
considéré par anticipation qu activités
de loisirs exclus est par essence les
activités politiques
les activités syndicales et les
activités cultuelles
dès lors opté une disposition dans le
droit ne nous permettrait quand bien
même nous en aurions l'envi et c'est pas
le cas d'appliquer le pas salutaire pour
tout événement de nature syndicale ou
politique et c'est encore une fois le
fruit du vote des sénateurs et là dessus
je peux vous dire que le consensus de 7
de la haute assemblée avait été
extrêmement large et appuyer sur cette
question
je ne sais pas qui a dit que la
vaccination a abandonné pourrait être
contre-productive pour les jeunes en
tout cas certainement pas le
gouvernement certainement pas le conseil
scientifique ni le conseil d'orientation
de stratégie vaccinale d'alain fischer
personne n'a considéré que la
vaccination des jeunes pourrait être
contre-productive la sénatrice on est
alors je vous je vous orient très
volontiers vers les sites
gouvernementaux et
les antennes et les orteils des agences
autorise des actes des autorités et
agences indépendantes
plutôt que je ne sais pas où vous avez
vu cela mais je vous garantis qu'on ai
je demandé à mon équipe avec grande
surprise aucun d'entre nous n'a pas
cette notion là les jeunes qui sont ne
sont pas vaccinés ne sont bannis de
nulle part madame la sénatrice puisque
des jeunes qui ne sont pas vaccinés ont
encore accès à des tests à foison et
gratuit et gratuit il n'y a pas
d'exclusion le sénateur alain richard a
posé ce qui me permettre je dis pas ça
pour horizon politique mais vous avez
posé une question particulièrement
sensible et en toute transparence
je me dois de vous dire que c'est une
question qui est éminemment complexe
vous l'avez souligné vous même
d'ailleurs sa réponse à la question de
la sénatrice goulet pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on n'intègre pas la
troisième dose dans le pass parce que le
troisième dose n'a rien à voir avec le
pass aujourd'hui donc la question ne
s'est pas posée jusqu'à présent si nous
devions s'il y avait une orientation des
autorités pour que nous intégrions la
troisième dose dans le pass sanitaires
alors ça poserait effectivement des
questions techniques assez fragile assez
sensible mais que quand je dis ça ça
veut pas dire qu'on peut pas le faire
mais c'est la question que vous posez
qui est technique mais puis 65 ans le
pass le reconnaît
les gens qui ont des comorbidités qui
n'ont pas 65 ans aujourd'hui le pasteur
que ne le reconnaît pas donc ça doit
faire l'objet de discussions à la voie
au niveau technique et médical pour
identifier les voies et moyens pour
permettre de nous assurer la protection
et parle par la troisième dose par les
deux rappels des gens qui sont dans la
catégorie des moins de 65 ans qui sont
appelés avant un rappel donc c'est une
question vous l'avez vous l'avez
souligné vous-même et j'admets bien
volontiers à ce stade ne pas avoir la
réponse mais on est en avance de phase
et je ne suis pas sûr que les autorités
sanitaires nous disent de mettre le
rappel dans le passé peut-être qu'ils
nous le dirons auquel cas on se posera
la question technique évidemment sur les
médecins libéraux et les non vaccinés
ils ont eu plusieurs fois l'occasion ils
l'ont fait d'ouvrir le fichier de leurs
patients vaccinés je peux vous dire que
si vous parlez avec les médecins de vos
territoires ils vous diront qu'ils
rencontrent les mêmes difficultés que
les maires que les centres de
vaccination ou que l'état aujourd'hui
ils ont face à eux des gens y compris
les personnes âgées qui se dit qu'ils
disent qu'elles sont très isolés qui
voit pas grand monde et qui veulent pas
qu'on les embête avec le vaccin où il
voit des jeunes qui disent que ils se
sentent pas concernés par le risque du
virus et qu'ils ont bien compris qu'ils
avaient un vaccin mais qu'il ne voulait
pas est ce que aujourd'hui un français
qui peut ignorer qui avec cinq autres
locaux vides qui lui proposait
gratuitement et qu'ils étaient incitées
à se vacciner je ne crois pas en tous
les cas nous continuons d'agir il ya
vingt-cinq mille médecins généralistes
qui utilisent de fichiers qu'il aurait
été envoyé par l'assurance maladie de
leurs patients non encore vaccinés
monsieur le sénateur bas je n'ai pas
souhaité dire si je les dis c'est pas
arrivé dans un long monologue c'est
parce que tu es dire que la situation à
la fin février serait la même
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai par contre je le dis
sans semble en difficulté je pense avoir
un certain nombre de soutiens ici rien
ne permet d'espérer que la situation
sera meilleure au coeur de l'hiver qu'au
début de l'automne
non mais c'est pas une question de
jugement c'est des questions de de
sylvain de monsieur le sénateur il ya
des années il ya des faits scientifiques
avérées pouvez vous pouvez considérer on
n'est même pas dans donnant de la dent
de la prédiction c'est vrai que j'ai
jamais fait de prédiction je me
risquerai jamais à vous dire est ce que
l'on me pose la question comment est-ce
qu'on est au début du cinquième vague je
n'ai pas de boule de cristal
on fait tout pour s'en prémunir et on
vaccine massivement pour que toute façon
vague ou pas wagon n'ait pas d'impact
sanitaire par contre vous dire qu'au
coeur de l'hiver les virus les virus
respiratoires circulent plus qu'au début
de l'automne c'est sûr ça c'est parce
qu'ils sont boule de cristal c'est une
question de données de la science
acquise depuis depuis des décennies est
observée dans tous les pays aient
observé y compris en france avec le co
lead donc la situation ne sera pas
meilleure à la fin du mois de février
qu'elle est aujourd'hui elle ne sera pas
meilleur il y aura toujours un minima
une circulation avec plusieurs milliers
de contamination par jour et donc de
toute façon nous ne pouvons pas nous
départir donc dans la mesure où je vous
ai dit qu'on a vous avez déjà plusieurs
fois à voter pour une prorogation des
mesures sur une durée plus longue que
celle que je vous demande aujourd'hui
j'entends bien que vous soyez
vous ne soyez pas disposés à voter mais
je vous redis la 2.2 village et il m'est
arrivé d'avoir des positions très souple
la fermeté du gouvernement quant à sa
volonté d'étendre la prorogation jusqu'à
la fin du mois de juillet les débats au
parlement auront lieu et c'est tout à
fait légitime
bien m'écouter s'il n'y a pas d'autres
questions
ouais ça vous regarde il nous reste à
vous remercier monsieur le ministre et
on remercie chacune et chacun d'entre
nous et je lève la séance nous levant la
séance par merci à vous
[Musique]